Okay, so our topic today is that is a transaction.
So if you remember, you take admission anywhere, right?
So at the time of admission, you either have to pay the registration fee,
or you have to pay the token, right?
Or you have to pay the prospectus fees, etc.
Is this part clear?
So in our module, we have that particular option,
like we have set up in this.
So the last thing we covered was that
where will your application number come from?
After the application number, how will you make your stage?
What stage do you want?
After that, your admission sources are set.
Now the point is admission tags.
Okay, you understood the tags too.
The main thing is that now we have to make a transaction with the student
in some or the other use.
Whether it is your prospectus, whether it is your token money,
or whether it is your registration fees.
Because when you take admission, you have to pay some amount
for admission at that time.
Is it okay, Tanvi Baba?
Yes, sir.
So what do we have?
We have a transaction receipt setup.
First of all, we have to do that.
Let me tell you the reason.
Whenever you get a receipt,
it has a number written on it.
Right?
Yes, sir.
So that number is automatically generated from the receipt counter.
So what we do here is we set the receipt number here.
We need one, two.
You have to put a prefix for it.
For example, if this is the University of SDI,
then I have put SDI.
So after SDI, three, four,
whatever the counter update is,
it keeps changing.
So you have to set the receipt number here.
Anything can happen.
Sometimes the client tells the client,
sometimes we make it ourselves by taking their initiation.
And after that, the number starts from one.
Here it is already counter updated,
so it is coming from three.
Is it clear?
Yes, sir.
After that, we have admission heads.
Now what is your point?
If you want to collect from any student,
then you have to do this.
The collection can be in any random head.
It can be your registration,
your prospectus fees,
one of which is your pocket money.
I will tell you about the concept of pocket money later.
Before that, let's go to the direct test
for registration and prospectus fees.
Registration and prospectus fees.
I have put these two.
These are my two heads.
Now in this head, my transaction will come
and in this head, my transaction can come.
Now the point is,
where will this head's transaction come from?
So you had a stage setup
What we will do is,
if you want to collect
from any head,
from any particular stage,
then you will view that stage.
For example, my lead stage.
If I want my child to pay me money in my lead stage,
then I will view that stage.
After viewing, I will go to transactions.
From here, the transaction will be enabled.
So from here, my transaction will be enabled.
Is it clear?
After the transaction is enabled,
what I will do from here is
add transaction mapping.
Now while adding transaction mapping,
we have all the respective courses.
They all come here.
Which course do you want to do?
Which head do you want the amount in?
You will select that.
For example, I have selected this head.
I have selected your registration.
In registration,
what I am taking from the child is
that I have to take 100 rupees from this.
I have put 100 rupees.
For example, registration P.A.
Now what does the system do?
It shows you that
editable.
So basically what happens is
when you go for registration,
then some children are like this
whose registration is done in 1000 rupees.
Some children are like this whose registration is done in 200 rupees.
Am I right?
It depends on how much
you convince the institute
that we will be able to give this much.
So if you keep this editable,
then while collecting the amount
for registration,
the amount will be editable.
If you keep it fixed,
then it will be fixed there.
For now, let's take this editable.
I have turned on the editable.
Now you will not add each one manually.
You will select one course,
then you select one course, then you select registration,
then you select another course,
then you add the amount.
So what do we have?
We have the option of copy course head.
As soon as you copy the course head,
then what will the system do?
It will add all the other courses.
Is this clear, guys?
Now you have two things.
You can get the amount collected
in a single head at one stage.
But in one stage,
you can also clear the amount in multiple heads.
You can also take prospectus at the same stage.
You can also do that.
You have to take registration at one stage,
you have to take prospectus at one stage.
So what will we do?
We will take registration at one stage and prospectus at the other.
At the end, I have updated this.
So if I refresh it and get it checked,
then the transaction required here
will be on.
This transaction required is on.
Nothing is coming in this case.
Getting my point?
Yes, sir.
Now we have the next stage,
the data requested stage.
So what will we do at the data requested stage?
We will go to the registration.
We have added one head there.
We will add one head here, which is your prospectus.
It depends.
If we are doing this for testing,
we can add anything anywhere.
But the client will tell you which particular head
you have to keep at which stage.
What did I do in this case?
In this case, I kept it only non-editable.
I came,
clicked on update after the last one,
refreshed,
recording is on.
Now I came to the application data image.
This is my specific lead.
Take an example.
This is my lead stage.
My application is at the lead stage.
When I will view it,
then after viewing it, we put a thousand rupees there.
So I can collect
this thousand rupees from here.
I can collect this thousand rupees from here.
You have collected
this thousand rupees
payment mode.
You have collected this thousand rupees.
Which head did you go to?
This is your thousand rupees.
We have added registration.
Clear?
Yes, sir.
I have collected it.
Now I will move it to the next stage.
I have collected
this thousand rupees.
I have collected this thousand rupees.
I have collected this thousand rupees in my transaction.
I have got my counter,
its receipt.
I came down, clicked on next,
clicked on update.
Now what will I do?
I can't go to the next stage,
the approved stage,
until I collect this thousand rupees.
I will collect this thousand rupees from here.
I clicked on save.
Now
I have collected this thousand rupees in my prospectus.
We have collected this thousand rupees.
Can you understand
from where did this come from?
Can you understand these things?
Yes, sir.
We had made a stage for this.
We made a stage for this.
We have set up a wall here.
Now we have
last but not least,
when we go to the next stage,
we have 1100 rupees more for collection.
Which we have set up here.
So you can see that the child has come to visit, that's why Steve East has to give it to him.
You go to the site tab, after going to the site tab, you have opened the same entity.
Then you have the transaction, what we do in the transaction, we delete everything.
And we will add the new single height that we have just made.
How many courses have come?
What I will do, I will go to add mapping, select add, put it in the visit fee, 1100 rupees.
I have saved it here.
I have added the amount, copied it and added it at the end.
Now when I go, see what was my first stage?
My lead stage, in that lead stage we collected 1000 rupees, which was in our registration.
Then our next stage was our stage, what is called from your data request, on which you collected 1200 rupees.
Am I right?
So from there you have collected 1200.
Now my last stage is where we are collecting another amount from the child.
That amount is yours.
The next stage you have selected, that amount is yours.
One thing you noticed, we had an editable there.
Now I can edit it, I can pay as much as I want.
We had kept the editable off before this, so we could not edit there.
If you remember, only this one was coming.
From here I have collected 11 rupees.
I have collected 11 rupees in the visit fee.
Now what is the point, understand this thing.
Okay, registration is done.
At this stage we have also collected it.
I will go to view transaction and show you.
Collect 1000 rupees, then you did 1200 rupees, then you did 1100 rupees.
Is the transaction part clear?
How to do the setup?
How to make the head?
At which stage will it be added?
Is that thing clear?
Yes.
Is the amount editable clear?
Is the amount editable on?
Is it clear?
Yes.
Good.
If your editable is on, enabled, then you can go there and edit the amount and collect it.
If you are not enabled here, then you can collect the amount set there.
Okay.
Now we have one more, that is your save zero amount transaction.
What happens in save zero amount transaction?
Guys, I will tell you a small thing.
Suppose you have turned on is amount editable.
Okay.
Now the user who is collecting the payment has added zero amount and collected it.
That is wrong.
Right?
Zero amount is nothing to collect, right?
Yes.
Okay.
So what we do, we will turn on save zero amount transaction in that case.
After that, it can save zero amount transaction.
I mean, we are bypassing it.
That some students are like this, they don't need to pay the registration fee.
Now if there is no need, then we can't define it student-wise.
So what do we do?
We have made a structure in which we have turned it on.
If any student wants to take zero there, then they can also take zero amount transaction.
Okay.
Now I will show you something like this.
Let's turn on is editable.
Okay.
And let's keep it off at zero.
Let's check one lead of BTEC.
Let's see what we have done.
We have turned on registration.
We have turned on is amount editable.
Now let's pick a specific course from here.
Which will be of this only.
Okay.
This is one I have read.
I have saved it in the next stage.
At the first stage, we are taking the entire payment because we had not turned on is editable.
I have saved it.
Okay.
At the next stage, as soon as I went to the registration, I came here.
Which one was it?
I had filtered this place.
Okay.
We have to see the transaction history.
You can see all the transaction history from here.
So remember this too.
Okay.
I opened it.
I collected 1000 rupees.
At the next stage, I have turned on is amount editable.
Now if I pay zero here, then the system will not let me pay zero.
Amount can't be zero.
Please enter a valid amount to proceed.
Did you understand?
Yes sir.
Now if I go there.
Is amount editable.
The one that is coming there.
Zero amount.
Safe transaction is coming.
If I enable that.
Okay.
I updated it.
I have clicked.
I have gone to the application data.
Okay.
I have clicked it from here.
At the next stage.
Now if I zero it.
Then it will let me save.
Now I can take the transaction of zero amount.
Did you understand?
What does zero amount enable mean?
So we have collected zero in this.
First it did not let me collect.
Is this clear guys?
Yes sir.
Okay.
Understand one thing.
This transaction part is clear.
You have to take registration fees.
You have to take prospectus fees.
You have to collect random xyz amount.
Whatever registration fees you give.
Or whatever prospectus fees you give.
Simply tell me.
Registration is sometimes adjusted in it.
In your fees.
But the money that you give to the other heads.
It does not get adjusted anywhere.
It goes directly to their account.
Okay.
Means you have one lakh rupees fees.
In one lakh rupees fees.
When you went for registration or admission.
They said that we need Rs.2500 or Rs.5000.
For prospectus.
You gave Rs.5000.
Now it will not be less than one lakh.
That is a different amount.
Is this clear?
Yes sir.
So because of this.
If we need a head.
Whose amount is less in it.
Means.
It means that you gave a token money.
That suppose I have one lakh rupees fees.
So I am getting admission now.
My registration that you have to take.
Or you have to take my prospectus.
That will be different.
But I have some extra amount.
Keep it in the name of my token money.
Which will get adjusted in my fees.
So what we do.
We have a head here.
Direct token money.
Okay.
This is directly selected.
You do not make it.
Okay.
You saved it.
This has become the head of token money.
Clear?
Now what we will do.
Now we have to take the token money at any stage.
Okay.
We have to take it at the end.
Usually we take it at the end.
Suppose we have to take the token money at the end.
Okay.
I went on this.
I added one more head of token money.
I put it in this.
Suppose 10,000 rupees.
Is it clear?
Guys, is it clear?
Yes sir.
Good.
Okay.
I saved it.
So basically.
Now what will happen.
When I will collect its fees.
Of this particular head.
Okay.
I went on data requested.
I collected zero on the first one.
I collected 1100 on the first one.
Now the point is.
Now I have 11,100 rupees.
Why?
Because our 11,100 rupees.
That we had already added as a visit fee.
And we added 10,000 rupees more.
What kind of token money will be made.
So what did it make combined?
What did it make combined?
11,100.
It has been adjusted.
It is not adjusted yet.
It has been summed.
Now we will collect all this.
We have collected 11,000 rupees from it.
We have collected 11,100 rupees from the child.
Now this money has gone in two things.
It has gone in the visit fee.
And it has gone in the token money.
Now what is the point guys.
Understand one thing.
You gave the money 11,100.
Okay.
But when the child's admission is approved.
So from its amount.
Suppose it has a fee of lakh rupees.
So the system will automatically adjust 10,000 rupees.
Do you understand?
Let me show you.
Let's make the fee structure of this child.
Suppose I put the tuition fee here.
1 lakh rupees.
1 lakh rupees is the tuition fee that I have added.
Now basically what will happen guys.
When I will approve this child.
Approve.
Whatever number you want to give.
Give the number to that child.
For now I have put the test.
Okay.
I have put the child.
Click on save.
Now the child is being approved.
Means the admission is done.
Now we are adding it to the student list.
Oh man.
I didn't even put the DO.
Sorry.
Okay.
Basically guys what happens.
You don't add the student manually.
You already have the data.
So you are transferring the child from one module to another.
Okay.
My child has been added here.
Now let me show you one thing.
When you go to the student list.
And search for the test student.
I have added this.
When you go to the fee.
And collect the fee.
We had put the fee of 1 lakh rupees.
Okay.
How much was the total fee?
1 lakh rupees.
Yes or no?
Yes sir.
Okay.
How much should have been the payable fee?
It should have been 1 lakh rupees.
But what did he do?
He gave 10,000 rupees in token money.
So when we approved the child.
And added him to the student list.
The system reduced his net balance by 10,000 rupees.
So now he has to pay only 90,000 rupees.
Are things getting clear?
Token money.
And is the difference getting clear?
Yes sir.
It is clear.
Okay.
So this is how you have to understand.
The token money that you have.
It will always be adjusted in its fees.
The rest of your heads.
They get collected directly.
They don't have anything.
They don't have to go anywhere and get adjusted in your fees.
Is that okay guys?
Yes sir.
Perfect.
Now tell me.
Is there any doubt in this?
Where did the head get added?
Why do we have to set the receipt counter of the transaction?
Okay.
After that go to stage setup.
What does editable mean?
Okay.
Go to editable.
Then what does save zero transaction mean?
Is this thing clear?
Yes sir.
It is clear.
Okay.
I am still repeating things.
Basically what happens when you take admission.
You have to pay some amount.
To pay the amount you have to have a head as well.
Like when you pay the fee.
It is tuition fee.
It is uniform fee.
It is examination fee.
At the same time of admission.
You have registration fee.
It is prospectus fee.
These are different heads.
So here we make heads in our admissions item.
In admission heads.
Okay.
In that also we have token money.
We don't have to add token money separately.
And this is not editable either.
From here it moves.
From here it is removed.
Okay.
Then comes the receipt counter.
Now when your transactions will continue.
It needs some counter here.
It needs 7, 8, 5, 2, 3, 1.
Whatever it needs.
It needs the number.
When your receipt is there it needs the number.
So here we set the number.
We do transaction receipt setup.
Is it clear?
Guys.
What's wrong?
After that what happens is.
We go to our stage setup.
Whatever I need to collect.
Whatever amount I need to collect.
I go to the stage and set it.
Suppose I need something on the first stage.
I need another head on the second stage.
I need another head on the third stage.
I need multiple heads in one stage.
So that is also possible.
Like we did in this.
Data is required in this one.
In the registration one.
We did it here.
Transaction.
After the transaction.
We have set two heads together.
For different courses.
We can do it separately.
Like in this course.
We are only taking the visit fee.
In this course we are taking both.
So what will the system do?
As soon as the child is approved.
After the payment is collected.
Your token money will be adjusted.
The rest of the fees will only be visible to you.
That this child had paid the fee.
Is it clear guys?
Yes.
This was all about your.
Transaction and token.